[Music]
[Car pulls up to house.]
[People laughing and chatting.]
[Ellen:] I guess we beat the Goodbodys here.
[Leona:] Who?
[Charlie:] The Goodbodys, the chaperones.
[Leona:] Oh yes, the Goodbodys, don't worry,
they'll be along.
[Charlie:] There. Here we are, the Mitchell ski
lodge, everybody welcome.
[Leona:] Ooooh, let's get the fire going.
[Charlie:] Right. The fireplace is laid, Ben, you light
it, will ya, I'll see to the kitchen stove.
[Dr. Ben:] Okay.
[Ladies glance at the two doors that read Guys,
Gals.]
[Leona:] Oh, those are the bunk rooms.
One lot for the gals and one lot for the guys.
All quite respectable.
Oh, match, doctor?
[Dr. Ben:] Oh thanks, Miss Ware.
[Leona:] Not at all, Dr. Edwards.
[Charlie:] Leona, come give me a hand, will you?
[Leona:] Okay. Miss Carver, will you kindly help Dr.
Edwards while I go and assist Mr. Mitchell?
[Chuckles]
[Dr. Ben:] Well, I guess it had better be Ellen and
Ben.
[Ellen:] I guess so. Like skiing, doctor? Ben.
Hahaha.
[Dr. Ben:] Yes, very much, but I don't get much of
an opportunity.
[Ellen:] We're not healthy enough in Melton? Is our
new health officer overworked?
[Dr. Ben:] Yes, to the first question.
[Music]
[Dr. Ben:] Beautiful night.
[Charlie:] Beautiful whiskey here. Why don't you
two have some?
[Dr. Ben:] No thanks, not just now.
[Ellen:] I'm happy with the coffee.
[Charlie:] Mustn't carry this health business too far, doctor.
[Leona:] If he doesn't want to drink, he doesn't.
Ellen never drinks anyway.
[Charlie:] Good for Ben to loosen up a little. Takes
life too seriously.  People resent that, you know.
[Dr. Ben:] Do they?
[Charlie:] Some people. Like Jeff Curran, for
instance.
[Dr. Ben:] What about Curran?
[Leona:] The alderman?
[Charlie:] The same. You've been on the job for
two months now Ben,
and you've got Curran down on you.
He's out to get you. So the grapevine tells me.
[Ellen:] What is all this Charlie?
[Charlie:] Well, Ben closed up a ratty little
restaurant in the south end, unsanitary.
Curran owns it.
So when Ben proposes that all civic employees
should be given blood tests,
Curran persuades the mayor, my esteemed father,
that this is an insulting slander
against old and honored citizens of the community.
The mayor listens. He always listens to Curran.
[Leona:] Blood tests?
[Charlie:] To discover what we delicately refer to as
the social diseases, my dear.
[Leona:] Ooooh.
[Dr. Ben:] Let's drop the subject, Charlie.
[Charlie:] Okay, but take my tip and go easy, my
friend.
Politicians don't like crusaders.
[Ellen:] Some politicians are crusaders.
[Charlie:] Whoops, I guess I put my foot in it.
[Leona:] What about some skiing?
[Ellen:] It's late.
[Dr. Ben:] Oh, it's only, uh...
Say, what happened to the Goodbodys?
[Charlie and Leona laugh.]
[Charlie:] They arrived hours ago. They're here.
[Ellen:] Here.
[Dr. Ben:] Where?
[Leona:] Us. We're the good bodies, all four of us.
[Charlie:] Get it? Good bodies.
We're going to be good boys and girls, so we don't need a chaperone.
Now don't tell me you had any other intentions. Naughty, naughty.
[Dr. Ben:] Your jokes aren't very funny, Charlie.
[Leona:] Aww, now Ellen, don't be mad.
We didn't want any of those killjoys around,
and we knew
you wouldn't come unless there were chaperones.
[Charlie:] Gee whiz, why does everybody have to
be so stuffy?
[Music as Dr. Ben walks out to the porch.]
[Ellen:] The pale, cold beauty of winter's mantle.
[Dr. Ben:] What's that from?
[Ellen:] From a book of poems I have.
[Dr. Ben:] I'd like to read them sometime.
[Ellen:] I'll lend it to you.
It's so fresh and clean out here.
[Dr. Ben:] Yes, Charlie's sense of humor is .....well.
[Ellen:] Maybe I am a little stuffy.
[Dr. Ben:] The chaperone business bother you?
[Ellen:] Not really.
It's just Charlie's attitude, and Leona's.
Think I'm being a Victorian?
[Dr. Ben:] If you are, that makes two of us.
Like to go skiing?
[Ellen:] Getting pretty late, isn't it?
[Dr. Ben:] I guess it is.
[Ellen:] Wasted trip, no skiing.
[Dr. Ben:] I didn't say it was wasted.
[Ellen:] Should we go in?
[Dr. Ben:] Cold?
[Ellen:] No.
[Dr. Ben:] Let's go for a walk down the road.
[Music swells as Charlie and Leona kiss on the couch.]
[Charlie:] Leona.
[Leona:] Don't.
[Charlie:] What's the matter with you?
[Leona:] You're so rough.
Why can't you kiss me nicely!
[Charlie:] Nicely!
[Leona runs off to the bedroom crying.]
[Dr. Ben and Ellen return from walk.]
[Charlie:] Been skiing?
[Ellen:] No, walking.
[Dr. Ben:] You should have come along with us,
Charlie.
[Charlie:] I'll say I should have.
[Dr. Ben:] Ellen and I feel we should go back to
town, Charlie.
[Charlie:] Okay, let's be proper by all means.
[Ellen:] I'll tell Leona.
[Sounds of car engine, straining to start]
[Leona:] That battery sounds awfully weak.
[Ellen:] This would happen.
[Leona:] Oh really Ellen, all this fuss.
[Dr. Ben:] All right Charlie, try it once more.
[Engine sounds]
[Charlie:] Look, Ben, you fix this blasted thing.
I'm staying, I'll get a bus down tomorrow.
And Leona can do what she likes.
[Dr. Ben:] That battery is completely shot now.
[Charlie:] Well, you three can walk 50 miles to Melton, I'm going to bed.
Good night.
[Leona:] I'm not walking anywhere.
Charlie's right.
All this silly nonsense.
[Ellen:] What are we going to do?
[Dr. Ben:] Well, it's quite a hike to Melton, even for
a couple of starchy Victorians.
[Ellen:] Well, good night.
[Dr. Ben:] Good night.
[Music]
[Dr. Ben:] Mr. Williams
[Mr. Williams:] How do you do, Dr. Edwards?
[Dr. Ben:] Won't you sit down?
[Mr. Williams:] Thanks.
[Dr. Ben:] What can I do for you?
[Mr. Williams:] No, what can I do for you?
[Dr. Ben:] I don't know what you mean.
[Mr. Williams:] Well, I want to cooperate.
I just heard about how you closed up that
place of Curran's.
That was a good move.
Anything that improves this town is okay by me.
I'm way ahead of most places in Melton.
You know my club, clean in every respect.
Now why can't all public places be like that?
No reason at all.
[Dr. Ben:] Agreed. So?
[Mr. Williams:] I'd like to cooperate.
[Dr. Ben:] That's very public-spirited of you.
[Mr. Williams:] Now don't think that I can't help.
I meet people see, in the club, outside.
I know everybody in Melton, and I've got plenty of
influence.
[Dr. Ben:] Probably you have, Mr. Williams,
but just what do you think you can do for this
department?
[Mr. Williams:] Well, I thought maybe you were
planning on some sort of
"Clean Up Melton" campaign.
If you are figuring on such a campaign, maybe I
can get behind you.
[Dr. Ben:] Possibly. I appreciate your interest, and
perhaps there is a way than you can help.
[Mr. Williams:] You name it, doc, and it's done.
[Dr. Ben:] Come here.
[They walk over to a map.]
[Dr. Ben:] This shaded area on the map represents
one of the worst slums in Melton.
If you can use your influence to help clear up
those slums, it would be a great service.
Should be easy for you since you own most of
those buildings.
[Mr. Williams:] Really, doctor, you seem to know a
great deal about my affairs.
[Dr. Ben:] That's my job, and I'm telling you, Mr.
Williams, if you don't clean up those slums, I will.
[Lively music]
[Patsy:] Marty?
[Mr. Williams:] I'm thinking.
[Patsy:] Oh, I'm going home.
Oh, Marty what's come over you?
If you're tired of me, just tell me, but don't freeze up on
me like this.
[Mr. Williams] Oh, lay off will ya?
[Patsy:] You want me to come up to your place
tonight?
No, I suppose not.
[Mr. Williams:] Now what are you worrying about,
I'm just as nuts about you as ever.
I'm busy, that's all.
I got things on my mind.
Your old man, beat it.
[Mr. Curran:] Was that Patsy?
[Mr. Williams:] Patsy?
No, maybe you saw Maura, the hat-check girl.
[Mr. Curran:] Are you seeing that Edwards guy
today?
[Mr. Williams:] This afternoon.
[Mr. Curran:] Well.
[Mr. Williams:] Hope to make trouble, I figure.
[Mr. Curran:] What'd he say?
[Mr. Williams:] Not much except to suggest I clean
up the slums I own on the south side.
If I don't, he will.
[Mr. Curran:] That all?
[Mr. Williams:] That's all he said.
[Mr. Curran:] If he gets too busy we'll take care of
him.
I have Shorty here keeping tabs on him.
Look Marty, you leave Patsy alone.
I know you're playing around with her; leave her
alone!
[Mr. Williams:] She drops in, no harm in that.
[Mr. Curran:] I don't want her having anything to do
with you.
[Shorty:] Marty?
[Mr. Williams:] What do you want?
[Shorty:] The boss got me watching Patsy, too.
[Mr. Williams:] What?
[Shorty:] Don't get sore Marty, don't get sore.
I'm only doing my duty, see.
Now suppose you slip me a fiver every now and
then, I don't even see Patsy at all here.
[Mr. Williams:] Okay, make it five a week.
[Shorty:] That's swell.
[Mr. Williams:] Just deduct it from the $200 you owe
me.
[Shorty:] Well, what do you know? I double-crossed
myself.
[Mr. Curran:] Shorty!
[Shorty:] Coming, boss.
[Patsy slides back into booth]
[Patsy:] Well, how do you like that?
Who does he think he is pulling his heavy father
act on me?
He's done nothing but snarl at me all my life.
[Mayor:] Naturally, you'll find your blemish in any
community, but, on the whole, I'd say that Melton
was one of the healthiest, most up-to-date little
towns anywhere on this continent.
Certainly one of the most go-ahead,
I know that for certain.
Of course, I haven't worked alone.
We're a team here in Melton.
And you know the secret of our success, Dr.
Edwards?
Patience and caution.
Go slowly and go solidly.
That is our motto.
[Charlie:] End of lecture, father?
[Mayor:] Don't be impertinent, Charles.
Oh by George, I must be getting along.
It's nearly 9 o'clock, got a committee meeting.
Well, it was nice to have seen you, doctor.
We must get together more often...keep each
other informed.
I shall be late, my dear.
Good night to you all, and the most stimulating
conversation, doctor.
[Charlie:] Father just loves stimulating
conversation, Ben.
I'll say this though, he's smooth.
That was a sugar-coated lecture, Ben.
[Mrs. Mayor:] What are you talking about?
[Charlie:] Ben was just warned to be a good boy or
he'd be dropped from the team.
It's as simple as that.
Curran has been needling his honor, I'll say.
[Mrs. Mayor:] Charlie, you talk in riddles.
[Dr. Ben:] He probably means very well.
[Charlie:] Always think the best, eh?
Good ole Mr. Goodbody.
Still touchy about that?
Ben and Ellen thought it was dreadfully immoral
not to have a chaperone at the lodge last
weekend.
[Mrs. Mayor:] Really?
[Dr. Ben:] Charlie exaggerates.
[Mrs. Mayor:] Chaperones are so outdated.
[Dr. Ben:] Are they?
[Mrs. Mayor:] Well now, don't tell me you're as old-
fashioned as that, Dr. Edwards.
Why, when I think of the harm done by chaperones
and stern parents...
[Dr. Ben:] Harm?
[Mrs. Mayor:] Yes harm. Policing people is useless,
doesn't do any good.
[Dr. Ben:] Sometimes they need guidance.
[Dr. Ben knocks on the door.]
[Daphne:] Having fun?
[Dr. Ben:] Good evening. I wonder if you could ...
[Daphne:] Come in, it's cold out there.
[Dr. Ben:] Is Miss Carver at home?
[Daphne:] Nope, the concert. Who are you?
[Dr. Ben:] Dr. Edwards. I just came to return ...
[Daphne:] That Edwards?
Let me have your coat.
[Dr. Ben:] Ben Edwards. I don't think I'll really stay.
[Daphne:] Why won't you stay? You came calling,
didn't you?
[Dr. Ben:] Well, not really.
[Dorothy:] Men always think they have to have
some excuse, Ellen ain't in...
[Dr. Ben:] Yes...
Howard and Marian are in though,
and they'll be glad to see you.
Nice folks.
Go and sit Ben. Marian! Howard!
Be here in a second.
[Howard Carter:] Hello there!
I've been fixing laundry tubs for Daphne.
Glad to see you.
[Dr. Ben:] Good evening.
[Marian:] Well, how nice!
[Dr. Ben:] Good evening. You're ahh...
[Daphne:] Howard and Marian Carter, Ellen's
parents.
Ben Edwards, doctor.
[Howard:] We're a bit informal around here,
Daphne's influence.
I hired her ages ago as my housekeeper,
and she's been running our lives ever since.
[Marian:] That was Daphne by the way.
Please sit down, Dr. Edwards.
[Dr. Ben:] Thank you.
[Howard:] I knew you the minute you turned
around,
saw your picture in the paper when you came to
town.
[Marian:] And Ellen has told us about you.
[Dr. Ben:] Oh yes, that weekend.
[Marian:] Oh, I didn't mean that.
Although it was so foolish of Charlie and Leona.
[Howards:] Not the fault of you and Ellen at all.
So you tackled Jeff Curran, eh?
Let me shake your hand again, Dr. Edwards.
Let's get acquainted.
Tell me all about this Curran affair.
[Dr. Ben:] So you see it's like trying to kill a weed
by mowing it down:
You destroy it here, and it grows up again
someplace else.
That's all we doctors and hospitals and social
workers can do.
Mow down the single manifestations of disease
and delinquency, but it takes group action,
community action, to uproot these weeds and
completely destroy them.
Oh gosh, I appear to have been babbling for
hours.
[Marian:] You haven't been babbling, Ben.
You've been talking sense.
[Howard:] I see what you mean, Ben.
As principal of the high school and a member of
the city council,
perhaps I'm a mower, too, instead of an uprooter.
[Dr. Ben:] I didn't mean ...
[Howard:] No, it could be true though. You've
missed something, Ellen.
[Dr. Ben:] Hello, how long have you been here?
[Ellen:] Oh, not long.
I'm sorry I'm so late.
Went down to the station to see Leona off.
[Marian:] Is she going away?
[Ellen:] Just to the city for a few days, that's all.
Charlie drove me home. He wouldn't come in
though.
Rushed off somewhere. Please sit down, Ben.
[Dr. Ben:] Oh, it must be getting very late.
[Marian:] Not too late for a cup of tea.
[Howard:] Yeah, let's have a cup of tea.
[Marian:] I'll go put the kettle on.
[Daphne:] It'll be ready in a few shakes.
My, this fellow Ben sure does talk, don't he.
[Marian:] Daphne, you are a wonderful woman.
[Couples dance as music plays.]
[Patsy:] Mind if I sit down here?
[Charlie:] Gee no, I mean please do. Have a drink.
[Patsy:] Nope.
[Charlie:] What's the matter, mad about
something?
[Patsy:] No. Where's your little girlfriend tonight?
[Charlie:] Gone to the city.
[Patsy:] So the mouse is playing, eh?
[Charlie:] Could be.
[Patsy:] Mmmhmm.
[Charlie:] Gee, that's quite a bracelet you've got.
Let me see.
[Patsy:] You know, if you take me somewhere else,
I'd love to have a drink.
I'm sick to death of this place.
[Charlie:] Okay fine, I know where we can go.
[Patsy:] Where?
[Charlie:] Some place nice and quiet. My ski lodge.
[Patsy:] Oh no, that's miles away and, besides...
I want a drink.
[Charlie:] Okay, we'll take a drink with us.
Where's Marty?
Marty, come here.
How about a bottle to go, Marty?
Can you get one from Joe?
[Marty:] Sure, why not?
[Patsy:] Sure, why not?
[Charlie:] Atta girl.
[Shorty:] Marty.
[Marty:] I thought you quit hanging around here.
[Shorty:] I gotta look as though I'm on the job.
Hey Marty, whatta I do now.
The boss said about you and Patsy,
not Patsy and anybody else.
[Mr. Williams:] Skip it.
[Shorty:] Okay, okay.
I got something for you on that doctor guy.
[Mr. Williams:] Yeah, what?
[Shorty:] Our boy Benny is a man about town,
a fast guy with the chicks, see.
He spent last weekend with Ellen Carter up in the Mitchell ski lodge.
Course this doll Leona Webb and young Charlie
is there too, but nobody else....
[Mr. Williams:] You sure of this?
[Shorty:] Am I sure? Am I sure?
Didn't I get it from my brother-in-law,
who's married to my third sister,
the one with the wart?
He runs the garage up in the mountains, see.
Last Sunday, he's called out
to the Mitchell ski lodge to start a car.
He figures out the whole deal, and he gives me a call.
We got an arrangement, see.
Lots of monkey business going on
in those ski lodges.
Da louse, he wants a cut.
And everything he makes her do...
Well, can you use it?
[Mr. Williams:] I can use it.
[Charlie and Patsy up at the ski lodge]
[Patsy:] Whew.
[Charlie:] Hang on a second.
I'll light the lantern and start a fire.
[Patsy:] Ahhhh, I think I've got a cold.
[Charlie:] I'll keep you warm.
You don't mind being kissed roughly, do you?
[Dr. Ben:] Good morning, gentlemen.
[Howard:] Good morning, Ben.
You know Tom McAllister?
[Tom McAllister:] Yes, we've met.
[Dr. Ben:] Is this an official visit?
You fellows look very businesslike this morning.
Anything wrong?
[Howard:] Plenty. Read this.
The marked item near the bottom.
[Dr. Ben:] The filthy rotten....
Operator, operator, get me the office of The Magpie.
[Tom McAllister:] What are you going to do?
[Dr. Ben:] I'm going to tell this editor
that he has a libel suit on his hands.
[Howard:] Don't be a fool.
What good would that do?
[Dr. Ben:] You can't knuckle under to stuff like this.
[Howard:] For heaven's sake,
think of Ellen, will you?
[Dr. Ben:] That's who I'm thinking of!
[Tom McAllister:] No one is asking
you to knuckle under.
We want you to fight.
[Dr. Ben:] What are we going to do?
[Howard:] About that, ignore it.
Can you see yourself and Ellen
being cross-examined by their lawyers?
[Dr. Ben:] Oh, look here Carter, it
will never come to that ....
[Howard:] My dear young chap, I know my
daughter, and I've come to know you and like you.
All I mean is you can't walk in mud
without being smeared.
It's not worth it for the sake of exposing a cheap
lie.
[Dr. Ben:] Well...
[Howard:] I got mad too when I read that thing.
Then I talked to Mac.
He opened my eyes.
[Tom McAllister:] This is more than a scandal, Ben.
Nasty little items like that are sold at a fat profit to the people concerned.
No one approached you?
[Dr. Ben:] No.
[Tom McAllister:] Nor Howard.
Why not?
Someone wanted that printed to discredit you, I'd
say.
[Dr. Ben:] But why?
[Tom McAllister:] Well, you've made enemies.
Made people uncomfortable. May do it again.
[Dr. Ben:] Curran? Williams?
[Tom McAllister:] Likely. It doesn't matter who, really.
[Howard:] Don't you see, this is more than a slur.
It's a challenge from the racketeer element.
[Dr. Ben:] Well, that's a little farfetched.
[Tom McAllister:] I don't think so.
Someone is out to get you.
[Dr. Ben:] What are we going to do about it?
[Tom McAllister:] We fight back.
After all, it's time we drove the racketeers out of this town.
[Howard:] Time we got at some of those weeds,
Ben.
[Dr. Ben:] Well, you know how I feel.
I'm with you all the way, but we three alone.
[Tom McAllister:] Alone! We won't be alone.
Do you think we are the only people in Melton
who want to see
an end to disease and crime and poverty?
Who want to uproot the weeds that infest this
community?
No.We'll find allies by the score.
But let's find them. Let's get to work!
[Dr. Ben:] Now you're talking.
[Tom McAllister:] So we felt our first move was to
call this meeting of representative
community leaders and discover if you shared our views as I've described them to you.
And if so, to enlist your support in devising a
means of action.
[Dr. Ben:] Modern medical cures are most effective, and yet the dangers are still great.
The venereal disease rate in most communities far
exceed the medical measures.
We must improve our treatment service
and our detection service.
Many, many people have syphilis and do not know it.
[Man 1:] Certainly we have the laws
to combat the problem of prostitution,
but we must see to it that those laws are enforced.
[Marian:] And we of the Women's League
have found time and time again
that the prostitute is jailed and fined, but the man, the patron, is permitted to go free.
His crime is as great as hers.
[Man 2:] I feel certain industry will welcome the
setting up of medical units to conduct
general examinations, lung, x-rays and blood test
among employees.
We businessmen will cooperate 100 percent.
[Dr. Ben:] Lung x-rays have uncovered a vast volume of tuberculosis,
and yet little has been done to enlarge our sanatorium facilities.
TB cases often have to wait their turn for
admittance.
And in the meantime the disease worsens.
[Minister:] In many parts of the country,
young people are required to have premarital
blood tests before they can apply for marriage licenses. Would this not be feasible in Melton?
[Priest:] We of the Roman Catholic Clergy
have very clear instructions to ask couples
contemplating marriage if they have exchanged prenuptial medical certificates,
and if they have not done so, we ask the reason why not.
[Man 2:] What about instruction on venereal
disease and sex knowledge in our schools?
[Priest:] The knowledge first of all should be given to the parents.
The adults of the community must be informed.
[Man 1:] We must have civic support
both moral and material.
We need authority and money.
I propose Mr. Carter, Mr. McAllister, and Dr. Edwards draw up a program for our approval
summarizing and implementing our findings here
tonight,
and present that report to the city council with the very least possible delay.
Let's waste no time.
[Tom McAllister:] We will do our level best
to represent adequately the
splendid objectives you have set forth here
tonight.
[Daphne singing off key.]
[Howard:] Daphne! Daphne!
[Daphne:] Coming! Somebody call?
[Howard:] Yes, I did.
That's a fine old hymn you were singing.
One of my favorites.
[Daphne:] Mine too, Howard.
[Howard:] I wish you wouldn't sing it though.
[Daphne:] Thought you liked it.
[Howard:] I do.
And I especially like the way you sing it.
But it’s distracting.
[Daphne:] 'Tis?
[Howard:] Those rich full tones come floating out of
the kitchen carrying those fine old words,
I get carried away and I can't work. And I have to finish this job tonight.
[Daphne:] Well, I'll just stop awhile.
Shouldn't be singing too much anyway.
Might strain my voice.
[Marian:] You worried about Curran?
[Howard:] I know what to expect from Curran,
but Higgins...
oh he's honest and means well, but not much vision.
And the mayor, a straw in the wind.
[Ellen:] Fifteen community leaders agreeing on a brief like this is a pretty strong wind, isn't it?
[Howard:] Should be, but Curran and Higgins,
dominate the mayor.
Of course, we’ll have McAllister backing us up.
[Doorbell rings.]
[Howard:] That must be Ben.
[Leona:] Evening, Daphne.
[Charlie:] No thanks, Daphne, we just popped in for
a minute.
[Leona:] To give you the good news.
[Marian:] What news?
[Leona:] We're going to be married.
[Ellen:] Leona!
[Marian:] All the happiness in the world, Leona.
[Howard:] Well, I hope you will be very happy.
[Charlie:] Thank you, Howard.
Say where's Ben?
I thought he'd be here.
[Howard:] He had to call in at the hospital,
but he's coming.
[Ellen:] Why don't you wait for him?
Come on Leona, come upstairs and leave your things.
[Leona:] Well, we might as well stay a little while.
[Howard:] Yes, let me have your coat.
[Leona:] Well, I finally nailed him.
[Ellen:] Leona.
[Leona:] I'll probably regret it for the rest of my life.
[Ellen:] Why do you say such things?
[Leona:] Oh, I know Charlie.
He's spoiled and selfish.
Marriage, it's not really what Charlie wants.
The only way he could have me is to marry me,
but I haven't much in the way of values.
Never was anyone to teach me anything.
Like Topsy, I just growed.
Oh, Ellen, you don't know what it means not to have any family.
[Ellen:] Leona, darling.
[Leona:] Ellen, I do love him.
I hope it works out.
[Ellen:] Of course it will.
[Leona:] What a goose I am.
[Ellen:] You're going to be very happy.
[Leona:] I hope so.
Let’s make it a double wedding, you and Ben.
[Ellen:] Leona, you idiot.
[Leona:] Now don't pretend you don't like him.
[Ellen:] Of course I like him.
[Leona:] And he's just crazy about you.
[Ellen:] Don't be silly.
[Dr. Black:] Hello Ms. Curran.
[Patsy:] Hello, Dr. Black.
[Dr. Black:] You know Dr. Edwards, I imagine.
[Patsy:] Well, what's the verdict?
[Dr. Black:] Oh, sort of nerve strain,
that's not too serious.
Only a matter of too many late hours,
too many parties, too much night life.
[Patsy:] And did you have to keep me here
for three days just to find out that?
[Dr. Black:] Takes time to make a thorough
examination.
Hospitals are the best place for diagnosis.
Here we can find out exactly what's wrong.
[Patsy:] But I am all right, aren't I? Well, aren't I?
[Dr. Black:] I'm afraid not. Your blood test showed something quite serious.
[Patsy:] What?
[Dr. Black:] I hate to have to tell you this.
You have a venereal disease, syphilis.
[Patsy:] Oh no.
[Dr. Black:] You've been infected for some time.
Probably several months, but don't worry.
With treatment, quite painless,
you can be completely cured.
[Patsy:] I don't believe it.
[Dr. Black:] I know this is a terrible shock for you,
but you'll have to face it, Miss Curran.
Face not only this disease, but your own responsibility.
That's why I asked Dr. Edwards to be here.
You can help him.
Help him a great deal.
[Dr. Ben:] Dr. Black has kindly agreed
to let me come and see you and ask your help.
I hope that you ...
[Patsy:] Help with what?
[Dr. Ben:] To help us trace down the source of this
infection and what's more,
help us discover any possible other infections.
[Patsy:] So what do you think I am, a street walker?
[Dr. Ben:] I'm not judging you, Miss Curran.
I'm a doctor with a job to do. You can help me do that job.
In fact, you can be of service
to the whole community.
[Patsy:] Oh, what do I care about
the community.
Get out of here, and let me alone.
Do you understand?
Get out!
Get out.
Oh, oh no.
[Howard:] What I have just read to you are
the words
and views of highly responsible, intelligent community leaders.
As such, they deserve the respect and most searching consideration of this council.
[Mr. Curran:] That all?
No specific proposals.
[Howard:] Some very specific proposals.
But before Councilman McAllister outlines
the program recommended by our group.
I want to emphasize the importance of the anti-VD phase of the program by means of a film.
Dr. Edwards secured this film, and it speaks for itself most graphically.
Dr. Edwards, perhaps you can set up your
projector right now ...
[Mr. Higgins:] Ah, this isn't a picture show.
Let's hear your program.
[Howard:] But it only takes a few minutes.
[Mr. Curran:] You've used up too much of this council's time already.
Get to the point.
[Mr. Mayor:] Let's view the film later.
If necessary.
A most impressive report.
I'm very anxious to hear its conclusions.
[Tom McAllister:] Gentlemen, here is a four-point health program for the city of Melton.
It's constructed so that private citizens
may work hand in hand with municipal departments,
sharing duties and costs.
Point 1: Legal requirements.
A law requiring all persons
to secure a general health examination,
including blood test
and lung x-ray before being issued a marriage license.
New laws if necessary and intensified
application of old laws.
To prosecute not only prostitutes
but all who derive profit therefrom:
landlords, madams, pimps, and those who maintain
prostitution by their patronage.
Point 2: Medical requirements.
The setting up in existing buildings of
a health center for the housing
of a VD clinic, a blood test department,
and headquarters for a mobile medical unit,
which would conduct general health examinations,
lung x-rays and blood tests at the request of
any individual or group of individuals.
I may say gentleman, that businessmen
among our group are especially
enthusiastic about this proposal.
[Mr. Higgins:] Why not, something for nothing.
[Tom McAllister:] Point 3: Citizen participation:
The creation of a permanent body of
representative citizens pledged to devise and carry
out a sustained program of adult and child education on community health in all its phases.
To be responsible for the raising by public subscription
of one-half the cost of the community center.
Point 4: Municipal participation:
The city to provide the proposed health
center referred to above.
The city to provide a suitable building site
and provide at least one-half the cost
of a large community center designed to accommodate sports facilities, stage productions,
public meetings, and a modest art gallery and museum.
The purpose of this center being to provide a constructive environment
for all the citizens of Melton.
There you have it gentlemen, a first and rough plan of attack against disease
and delinquency in this city.
[Mr. Higgins:] What kind of wild-eyed
nonsense is this?
[Mr. Curran:] This whole plan is an insult
to the good people of Melton.
[Mr. Higgins:] An insult?
It's a fantastic slander.
It suggests that Melton is a city populated by
diseased prostitutes
and degenerates, young and old.
And the cost, staggering, hundreds of thousands
of dollars.
[Dr. Ben:] The cost would be a lot cheaper in the long run, than the present cost of curing disease.
[Mr. Curran:] You're not a member of this council,
Edwards.
[Howard:] Gentlemen please.
[Mr. Higgins:] Are you going to have sex education
for children,
expose our youngsters to stuff like that?
[Tom McAllister:] I've explained that sex facts are only a part of a broad...
[Mr. Higgins:] But sex would be a part.
[Mr. Curran:] These blood test, x-rays,
how many people really need them?
[Mr. Higgins:] What do these fools want to do,
stick needles in everybody in town?
Treat our young people like brute cattle?
[Mr. Mayor:] I feel that all these things
could be carried out in the sanctity of the home.
After all, any sensible, concerned father knows
his duty in this regard.
[Howard:] Then the fathers of this community
are neither sensible or concerned.
[Tom McAllister:] Gentlemen, we've given you
one damaging statistic after another.
The alarming incidence of venereal disease, here in Melton.
The consumption of alcohol by minors.
The volume of moral delinquency.
The crowded sanatariums right here in this city.
Can you possibly ignore these facts and bleed
about costs and crackpots?
Call the facts offensive if you wish, but as representatives
of the people you dare not turn your backs on them.
Nor on the need for a program of action.
[Mr. Curran:] Perhaps we let this idea take us by
surprise.
Let's study it.
I move that a committee of three be appointed
to investigate and report back to the council.
[Tom McAllister:] I second that motion.
[Mr. Higgins:] I nominate Curran.
[Tom McAllister:] Carter.
[Curran:] This is a mighty important committee.
I think the mayor should be on there.
[Mr. Mayor:] I'd be delighted, gentlemen.
It is an important committee.
[Mr. Higgins:] Well you got three, now let it go at
that.
[Mr. Mayor:] Is that your wish, gentlemen?
[Mr. Higgins:] Anyway, I move we adjourn.
[Mr. Curran:] Second it.
[Howard:] The film, you should see the film.
[Mr. Higgins:] Let the committee see the film.
[Mr. Mayor:] When do we meet?
[Mr. Curran:] I'll call you.
[Dr. Ben:] Well, at least we got a committee.
[Mr. Howard:] Yes, we go through a farce of
meetings.
[Tom McAllister:] And Curran will try to talk the plan
to death, an old strategy of his.
There will be a whispering campaign, opposition generated.
If we ever get to the public with this idea they'll be so influenced against...oh well.
[Mr. Howard:] The public. Mac, that’s it.
We won't wait for Curran to get in his dirty work.
We'll take this idea to the people themselves.
[Tom McAllister:] The annual town meeting?
[Mr. Howard:] Exactly!
But we'll have that meeting primed:
speeches, leaflets, polls.
We'll start a publicity campaign between now and the meeting.
[Dr. Ben:] Hey, what meeting, what’s that?
[Tom McAllister:] Once a year the council meets
in the presence of the public, an old custom here.
[Mr. Howard:] Ben, my boy, as somebody said somewhere, we've only just begun to fight.
[Newspaper presses running.]
[Dramatic music playing as newspaper headlines are displayed.]
[Dr. Ben:] Look, even the decent newspapers are against us.
[Ellen:] I can't understand it, why?
[Dr. Ben:] Ahhh, I guess it’s so easy
to stir up prejudice and fear.
[Ellen:] Poor dad.
He's worried sick, blames himself over what's
happening.
[Dr. Ben:] It's not his fault.
Curran and his tribe distorted everything.
[Ellen:] Well, we just have to keep on fighting.
[Dr. Ben:] You're a tower of strength. Ellen?
[Charlie:] Hi folks, am I breaking something up. I'll bet!
[Ellen:] Hello, Charlie.
[Charlie:] You ready to go Ben?
[Dr. Ben:] Ready?
[Charlie:] Up north to the ski lodge,
to help fix up for the honeymooners?
[Dr. Ben:] Awww, I've been so busy Charlie,
I guess I forgot.
I don't think I'll be able to make it.
[Charlie:] You haven't a single appointment, I just
checked.
[Ellen:] Why don't you go, Ben?
The drive will do you good.
[Dr. Ben:] Will you come?
[Ellen:] I can't really, but you go please.
[Dr. Ben:] Okay.
[Charlie:] Ellen you have him well-trained.
I bow to you, my pet.
[Ellen chuckles.]
[Music playing.]
[Charlie:] Leona can have her flowers,
I'll take pine needles. Here grab some of that.
[Dr. Ben:] Yeah, yeah.
[Charlie:] My little wife-to-be will probably
chuck this stuff out once she sees it.
Women hate to have things arranged for them.
Like to do it themselves.
You'll find that out soon enough, Ben, if you ever
stop chasing germs and start chasing women.
Well, I guess my chasing days are over.
[Dr. Ben:] Well, they should be.
You've chased and caught a very lovely girl.
See that you deserve her.
[Charlie:] Yes, doctor.
Say, the place looks good, eh?
[Dr. Ben:] Neat as a pen.
What's this?
[Charlie:] Oh, some trinket of Leona's.
I'll take that.
[Patsy Curran is engraved on the bracelet.]
An ancient indiscretion.
[Dr. Ben:] How ancient?
[Charlie:] Chap doesn't discuss these things.
[Dr. Ben:] He does with his doctor.
[Charlie:] A few weeks ago.
[Dr. Ben:] When Leona was in the city?
Very ancient.
[Charlie:] Hang it all, Ben.
Stop talking like a made man.
What business is it of yours anyway?
[Dr. Ben:] Come on, we're going back to my office.
[Charlie:] Honestly Ben, this is a lot of rot.
All right, give me your old blood test,
but don't interfere in my private life.
[Dr. Ben:] I've told you it takes time
for us doctors to make sure.
If you are going to be a silly young fool running
around,
you owe it to your future wife to make absolutely
certain.
You can't get married until you are.
[Charlie:] How long is that?
[Dr. Ben:] Might take ten weeks or even longer.
[Charlie:] Postpone the marriage indefinitely.
I should say not.
[Dr. Ben:] Silly young fool.
[Charlie:] There are these new drugs, even if
anything were wrong.
[Dr. Ben:] 391
[Patsy:] Hello.
[Dr. Ben:] Hello Miss Curran, this is Dr. Edwards.
[Patsy:] Yes.
[Dr. Ben:] I'd like for you to come over to my office
immediately.
[Patsy:] Well look, Dr. Edwards, I've got absolutely nothing to talk to you about.
[Dr. Ben:] I have Charlie Mitchell here, and your bracelet.
[Patsy:] Oh, all right.
As soon as I can.
[Dr. Ben:] Goodbye.
Better sit down.
[Men are gathered around a meeting table.]
[Mr. Curran:] Thought I told you not to come up
here.
[Shorty:] I've got something very important, boss.
[Mr. Mayor:] Good government, Higgins, is cautious
government.
Go slowly. Be sure, be patient.
[Mr. Higgins:] Patience and caution, go slowly and
solidly.
[Mr. Mayor:] Yes, exactly.
[Mr. Curran:] Listen to this, Mitchell.
[Shorty:] I'm downstairs see, waiting for you, boss,
when in through a side door comes Patsy.
"What she doing here," I think?
I follow her down the corridor to the back.
She goes into Edwards' office.
I'm surprised, you get me.
We don't go for this Edwards guy, do we boss?
What's Patsy doing...
[Mr. Curran:] Never mind that.
[Shorty:] Well, I'm curious, see.
So I tippy-toe into the other room, empty,
but in the other office I hear voices.
Edwards, Patsy, and your kid mayor.
[Mr. Mayor:] Charlie?
[Shorty:] The same.
[Mr. Curran:] This guy Edwards is up to something.
Come on Mitchell.
[Charlie:] Look Ben, will you get to the point,
whatever it is?
[Patsy:] Yeah, what do you want anyway?
[Dr. Ben:] I want you to tell Charlie the truth.
[Charlie:] What do you mean?
[Patsy:] Well, you're not tongue-tied?
You had to drag me down here for that.
[Dr. Ben:] You're the only one to speak.
It's your duty. I don't seem to be able to convince you of that.
[Patsy:] You're not going to pry into my life.
[Charlie:] Look, will you get to the point?
[Dr. Ben:] Very well. I'm going to show
you something and after you've seen it,
perhaps you'll come over to my point of view,
and realize how important it is
for both of you to cooperate with me.
[Charlie:] What's the meaning of this?
[Mr. Curran:] Never mind that.
What's he got on you two?
[Dr. Ben:] Curran, this is a doctor's office.
What goes on in here is secret.
[Mr. Curran:] I wonder.
You might be digging for dirt against our two kids
in order to force Mitchell and me to back your lousy health campaign.
To make a big name for yourself.
[Dr. Ben:] You might have told your family
as your doctor instructed you to.
[Mr. Curran:] Told what? Answer me, what's he talking about?
[Patsy:] Oh, leave me alone.
[Charlie:] Ben, you mean there is really something
wrong?
[Mr. Curran:] Patsy, tell me.
[Patsy:] Well, if you must know, I've got syphilis.
[Dramatic music.]
[Mr. Mayor:] Charlie?
[Charlie:] I guess I maybe...
[Dr. Ben:] I asked Patsy and Charlie here together so they could see what might happen to them.
It's doubtful that it will happen, thanks to science, but it could happen.
I think it’s most appropriate that you two gentlemen
dropped in.
You need to see these films I have here
as much as your children do.
Sit down gentlemen.
[Sounds of projector being set up, and music as film opens]
[Narrator:] Syphilis the crippler,
the destroyer, the killer.
Usually contracted sooner or later by men
associating with prostitutes
or indulging in promiscuous sex relationships.
So often acquired by girls who foolishly become sexually intimate
with men they meet as dance hall pickups.
Or at the drinking parties.
And the story of Jerry Anderson again and again.
[Doctor 1:] What's your name?
[Jerry Anderson:] Jerry Anderson.
[Doctor 1:] Jerry Anderson.
How did you happen to come into the clinic?
[Jerry Anderson:] Well, I couldn't afford to
go to a private doctor.
I didn't know what to do.
I called the county health department to see
if they couldn't do something for me.
I was told to come see you.
[Doctor 1:] What's your trouble, Jerry?
[Jerry Anderson:] Well, I've got a pretty bad sore
down here.
[Doctor 1:] Umhmm.
Why don't you stretch out on that table over there?
We'll have a look at you.
Come over here.
I want you to see this little cork screw devil
that's causing all your trouble.
Look.
This darkfield test shows up the spirochetes.
Can you see them wriggling back and forth across
the slide?
[Jerry Anderson:] Yes, what did you call them?
[Doctor 1:] Spirochetes.
Those are the germs that cause your syphilis.
[Jerry Anderson:] Well, I guess that finishes me.
I'll have to leave home, quit school, and go
someplace where people don't know who I am.
[Doctor 1:] Now Jerry, you know can't meet any problem by running away from it.
You may not realize it, but you're a very lucky young man,
because we're catching this in time to cure you.
Ms. Jones, prepare a 4/10ths neo-injection, please.
[Jerry Anderson:] Yes, but doctor I can't take a chance on the folks
or their kids at school finding out that I have
syphilis.
[Doctor 1:] Now don't worry about it.
You can go about your class work, play basketball,
tennis, or indulge in any other sport.
Sit down here please and roll up your sleeve.
And nobody need ever know that you have
syphilis.
But you have to report every week, and not miss a
single treatment at least for one year.
[Jerry Anderson:] Well, that's a relief.
I feel like living again.
Gee doctor, that didn't hurt a bit.
I'd always heard that shots for syphilis were
painful.
[Doctor 1:] Not if you go to a doctor who knows his
business.
[Jerry Anderson:] I don't know how to thank you,
doctor.
[Doctor 1:] Just come into my office, and give me
the name of the girl that infected you.
That's all the thanks I want.
Come along.
[Jerry Anderson:] Gee doctor, I kinda hate to do
that.
I'm no stool pigeon.
[Doctor 1:] Sit down here, please.
Now Jerry a lot of men have a false sense of
chivalry about giving the name of the
woman that infected them.
We're not going to do anything harmful to the girl,
and your name won't be brought into it.
We only want to bring her in for examination and
treatment.
[Narrator:] Jerry has done his part.
Now the health department swings into action to do theirs.
This health official studying the information on
the card sent into the department by the doctor
who examined Jerry Anderson rings for a visiting
health nurse.
After discussing the case for a few moments,
the nurse sets out to locate the girl,
and, in a friendly way and confidential interview,
suggests that the girl visit the clinic
in the interest of her own health and welfare.
Upon reporting to the clinic for an examination and
interview, a sample of the girl's blood is taken
and sent to the departmental laboratory for
analysis.
This contact or suspected contact follow-up
procedure is very important to the individual
concerned because so often they do not even
suspect they are suffering from venereal disease.
The laboratory examination of the blood sample,
generally known as the Wasserman test,
is a complicated procedure requiring close
attention to detail.
It is entrusted only to thoroughly skilled personnel
who handle these tests quickly
and efficiently by number.
They never know the name of the patient involved.
In this instance, the test confirmed
that Jerry's sex partner had syphilis.
There is no doubt of it.
The laboratory report is positive.
Syphilis has struck and its germs are implanted
in new victims once again.
Just a little over three weeks since Jerry met the girl who infected him with syphilis,
which began in her case most probably through intercourse with an infected person
prior to her relations with Jerry Anderson.
Now we see what really happens in such a case
as the germs of syphilis, called spirochetes,
attack the cervix or neck of the uterus
within the female reproductive system.
Shortly after infection, the primary lesions,
or chancres as they are commonly called,
appear as small, red sores where the spirochetes entered the bloodstream.
Such as the labia, or lips of the vulva,
on the vaginal wall, and the cervix.
Since these sores are painless
and often well concealed within the female organs,
it is easy to understand why women in particular
can be infected and never know it.
Syphilis can also, in very rare cases, be acquired
by kissing a person with a chancre on the lips,
and occasionally doctors and nurses contract it
in handling syphilitic patients,
in which event the chancres appear on the finger like this.
Throughout the primary stage and during the quiescent period of from six weeks to three months
following the appearance of the chancres,
the germs are disseminated to all parts
of the body via the bloodstream,
their natural highway network reaching
to every vital organ of the human system.
The disease now enters upon what is known as the
secondary stage,
and various manifestations may begin to appear, either singly or in combination.
Such as headaches.
Accompanied by general feeling of depression
of being unwell, with perhaps sores in the mouth,
sore throat, or swollen glands.
The infected bloodstream may give rise
to skin rashes on the body and face.
Or the hair roots may be affected and unsightly
patches appear at different places.
Or as so often happens, a general falling of the hair during combing, from all parts of the scalp.
Health authorities have ascertained
by careful checking of their records,
that one case of syphilis usually results in three
more.
And those three, another three.
Therefore it is your duty, yours and mine,
should any of these manifestations appear,
such as headaches, sores in the mouth,
sore throat, swollen glands, skin rashes, hair patches, etc., especially after exposure
through illicit sex relations, to report to a private physician or health clinic for examination and a blood test.
Which is simplicity itself, and when carried out by a skilled operator,
is so painless as to be almost unnoticeable.
A tourniquet is first applied to the arm,
which is then thoroughly cleansed with alcohol.
A large syringe is now deftly inserted into a vein
and a quantity of blood
slowly withdrawn for laboratory analysis purposes.
And that’s all there is to it.
Bets.
The beneficial results may be far reaching
and save untold misery
and unnecessary suffering in later years.
If in doubt at anytime don't delay,
get a blood test today.
Your own health and the health of your loved ones
is far too precious to gamble away.
Time is the all-important factor
in the war on syphilis.
Prompt treatment by a qualified physician
or at a health clinic is insurance
against the devastating effects of late syphilis.
Which may appear anywhere from five to ten,
fifteen, or even twenty years
after the original infection,
If the disease is not detected and treated in the early stages.
The heart attack, the usual cardiac symptoms,
associated with heart trouble--
in reality syphilis in disguise--
because syphilis will simulate
practically every disease known to medical science.
Stricken without warning,
from the very depths of our being.
Even death, yes, is often the penalty paid
for neglect of this scourge of the human race.
When the spirochetes attack the optic nerve,
blindness can be
the tragic aftermath of this fearful disease.
If and when they invade the central nervous system, locomotor ataxia,
paralysis of the lower limbs, often occurs.
But when they attack the brain,
then we pay the terrible price of paresis
with the pitiable hallucinations, gradual loss of
speech, eventual mental unbalance, and death.
Tragic human wrecks on the casualty list of the
great destroyer.
[Man babbling]
[Interviewer:] Tell me how is your memory?
[Man Interviewed:] Memory 100 percent?
[Continued babbling "God bless you, Happy New
Year"]
[Interviewer:] How are your spirits?
[Man Interviewed:] Spirits 100 percent.
[Interviewer:]Are you happy? You're happy?
[Man babbling]
[Interviewer:] I want you to say this after me,
lovely, lily, lemon.
[Man interviewed:] Lovely, lily, lemon.
[Interviewer:] Lovely, lily, lemon.
[Man interviewed:] One hundred percent.
[Interviewer:] Truly rural.
[Man interviewed:] Truly lurul.
[Man interviewed:] Truly tlulul.
[Interviewer:] Liquid electricity.
[Man interviewed:] Liquid ectricity.
[Narrator:]  In these late cases of syphilis,
the spinal tap is often the only means
of determining the true cause of the patient's
condition.
Like the blood test we saw earlier,
the technique involves insertion of a needle,
only this time a hollow one into the spinal canal.
And the spinal fluid for the laboratory analysis is caught in test tubes
as it drips through the hollow needle from the spinal column.
Today in view of all that is known about syphilis, many physicians take a spinal as an extra measure
of precaution in all cases of patients receiving
antisyphilitic treatment
before discharging them as completely cured.
[Butcher painting store window]
[Inaudible talking]
[Ambulance arrives]
[Butcher Tony:] I got everything all ready doctor.
My wife she’s in this room, and she got her sister with her too.
Please doctor, hurry up, huh. I'll stay right here, waiting for the good news.
What you want let me get on and finish in peace.
Outside. [Inaudible]
Thank you, everybody.
[The doctor delivers the baby.]
[Butcher playing accordion as he waits.]
[Butcher Tony:] What's a matter doc?
Don't you want to tell me she's a boy?
He's a boy, no?
[Doctor:] Yes Tony, it's a boy.
[Butcher Toni:] My Maria, Maria, she's okay?
[Doctor:] She's all right.
[Butcher Tony:] My bambino's all right, my Maria's all right, but your face isn't all right.
What's the matter?
[Doctor:] Tony, your son was born dead.
[Tony drops the accordion.]
[Butcher Toni:] My first bambino is dead.
What's that?
[Doctor:] Well, I've got a pretty good idea,
But I’ll have to ask you a few questions first.
[Butcher Tony:] Questions, what questions?
[Doctor:] We’re not done Tony, I better wait until your wife feels better.
[Butcher Tony:] Oh please, now you’re driving me crazy. What's happened?
[Doctor:] All right.
Did anyone ever tell you Tony, that you've got syphilis?
[Butcher Tony:] Syphil... What are you talking about? I ain't got no syphilis.
[Doctor:] Take it easy. Think, I want you to think
back carefully.
Do you remember ever having a sore
that didn't heal very fast?
[Butcher Tony:] No, no I never...
Yes, about two years ago, before I was married.
I got a little sore, but I got a salve and put it on it
and it was cured.
[Doctor:] It might make the sore go away, but no medicine you could buy ever cured syphilis.
[Butcher Tony:] I got syphilis?
[Doctor:] I'm almost sure syphilis killed your baby, Tony.
You see, a syphilitic sore will go away without any treatment in time, but the germs stay in your body.
[Doctor:] Yes Tony, I'm afraid that you gave Maria syphilis, and she gave it to the baby.
[Narrator:] Sins of the father visit upon such
babies, and these children born deformed,
unsightly and handicapped throughout their life.
Or like this little boy with the doctor,
deaf for the rest of his life.
Venereal disease can be cured.
Thanks to medical science.
And particularly syphilis can be completely stamped out,
if all engaged couples went to a doctor for a premarital consultation,
a thorough physical examination before marriage, and a routine blood test.
If every expectant mother made certain that she received adequate prenatal care,
including the routine blood test early in pregnancy, then congenital syphilis could be stamped out.
If we demanded and supported routine blood tests
for employees in every industry,
if we demanded and supported adult classes of instruction in sex education.
And if we all, whenever our own status was in doubt, reported to a private physician
or a health clinic and asked for a blood test, then indeed the day would come when everyone would
know for sure, and syphilis would become a disease of the past within the very near future.
[Dr. Ben, Pasy, Charlie, and their fathers are sitting in the doctor's office.]
[Dr. Ben:] That is what I tried to show at the council
meeting the other night.
That is part of what the four-point program is aimed against.
That's all gentlemen.
[Charlie:] Ben? It will be all right? In time?
[Dr. Ben:] Yes. We can cure this disease.
We can cure the body that is,
but the spirit is something else.
It might bear permanent scars.
That's up to you.
[Charlie:] Thanks Ben.
And we'll do whatever you say.
[Patsy:] May I go now?
[Dr. Ben:] Yes.
It will be all right Patsy, don't worry.
[Mr. Curran:] Patsy! It's all my fault, baby.
[Patsy:] Oh dad!
[Dr. Ben:] Let me repeat, Curran.
All this is between the five of us.
[Mr. Mayor:] You mean that this won't get out?
No one will know?
[Dr. Ben:] I think I made that quite clear, Mr. Mayor.
[Mr. Mayor:] Yes, but the wedding will have
to be postponed, and people do...
Then there's the health program?
[Dr. Ben:] Our differences are not political ones.
We are not fighting for power, for votes.
We're fighting disease, stunted minds, and stunted
bodies.
[Charlie:] Come on, dad.
[Dramatic music.]
[Charlie:] Well, that's it.
[Leona:] What do you have to do?
[Charlie:] Well, I'll move to the city.
Father's fixed up a job for me, and Ben has
arranged for treatments there.
It'll, it'll look quite normal to postpone the wedding.
[Leona:] Postpone it?
[Charlie:] Leona, are you through with me?
[Leona:] No. No, I love you Charlie.
I guess I'll always love you no matter what you do.
But you spoiled something.
Something is gone that we'll never get back.
[Charlie:] I'll try and make up for it.
[Howard:] I know this town Ben.
I doubt that we'll pull it off tomorrow night.
Oh, I'm not condemning the people of Melton.
They’re as decent and intelligent as any people
anywhere,
but they've been led up the garden path by our
opponents.
[Ellen:] Mrs. Jamison asked me today if you would be jailed if you didn't have a blood test certificate.
[Howard:] You see a fine kindly women,
she's been made to fear us.
[Marian:] Howard dear, you've done your best,
you, and Ben and the others.
Now if you are turned down tomorrow, you'll have
to start a long slow campaign, but you will do it.
We’ll all do it.
Now please, try to relax and have a pleasant
evening.
[Howard:] You're right as usual.
[Daphne:] Through here?
[Marian:] Yes, thank you, Daphne.
Go home, they’ve postponed the weeding.
[Daphne:] Bad luck.Take Hester Thompson for instance.
All set to marry in November 1919.
Hester's Ma got the flu, so had to put the wedding
off till after Christmas.
Come January, Alex's store burnt down,
had to put the date off till June.
Come June, Hester fell down, broke her leg.
Well sir, from then on, just one thing after another.
Got so bad, Alek took to drink.
Hester took to consulting the stars,
trying to find a favorable day.
Them two still ain't married.
Hope there's no such backing and stalling
when Ben and Ellen get married.
[Dr. Ben:] Daphne!
[Howard:] Saved by the bell, eh Ben?
Hello?
Oh hello, Curran.
Yes, I imagine that's all right.
Just a minute.
Curran wants to see you and me in your office tonight.
[Dr. Ben:] Tell him yes.
[Howard:] Hello Curran.Yes, that would be all right. About half an hour.
Right.
[Marian:] What does Curran want?
[Howard:] I don't know? Said he just had to see us.
[Dr. Ben:] Well, let's go and find out.
[Marian:] Maybe it's a trick.
Maybe you shouldn't go.
[Dr. Ben:] I don't think it’s anything like that.
Well, Mr. Curran, take a chair.
[Mr. Curran:] I'll stand.
I haven't much to say.
[Dr. Ben:] As you like.
[Mr. Curran:] I came to give you something.
Carter, I want you to swear you won't open this
or try to find out what’s in it for two weeks.
[Howard:] Can I decently and honestly make that
promise?
[Mr. Curran:] I give you my word, for what it's worth.
[Howard:] Very well, I'll do as you say.
[Mr. Curran:] One more thing.
Don't bring up your health program tomorrow
night. You'll kill it if you do.
[Dr. Ben:] We're prepared to risk that.
[Mr. Curran:] Don't bring it up. Get it postponed.
[Howard:] I'm not going to let you win that easily.
[Mr. Curran:] I don't want to win anymore. I won't oppose you.
[Dr. Ben:] You what?
[Mr. Curran:] I won't oppose you.
[Dr. Ben:] Then support us.
If you do, we'll put it over tomorrow night or any
night.
The whole town....
[Mr. Curran:] Don't let the issue be
decided tomorrow night. Wait.
Wait two weeks.You promised.
In two weeks, that will win for you.
That's all.
[Howard:] You think Marian is right, this is some
trick?
[Dr. Ben:] No, I don't think so.
[Dramatic music]
[Mr. Mayor:] I can't reach him.
I've tried for an hour.
We can't wait much longer.
[Mr. Higgins:] Curran has never missed
a meeting in his life.
[Mr. Mayor:] Yes, but he is half an hour late
already. We'll have to go in soon.
[Tom McAllister:] What do you make of it, Howard?
What's Curran up too?
[Howard:] I don't know.
Look Mac, if things appear to be going against us,
let's press for a postponement
on the grounds the committee hasn't completed its study, right?
[Tom McAllister:] Well, I thought you were all
for going ahead tonight.
[Howard:] I've changed my mind.
Got a hunch.
[Mr. Mayor:] We go in.
We can't wait any longer.
[Audience claps]
[Mr. Mayor:] Citizens of Melton, welcome to this annual meeting.
Gentlemen of the council, this is our agenda for
this evening.
The minutes of the last meeting, street lighting in ward three,
the resurfacing of Hawthorne Street, and the report from the special committee
to discuss community health.....
[Groans from those in attendance]
[Mr. Mayor:] [Slams gavel]  Please abstain from
these outbursts.
This meeting must proceed with decorum.
Gentlemen, we will proceed with our business.
[A telephone lies off the hook; packed suitcases are seen.]
[Mr. Curran:] How much time have we got?
[Patsy:] Not much, about twenty minutes.
Why isn't Shorty here?
[Mr. Curran:] I called him only for the last minute.
What time is it?
[Patsy:] About six after nine.
We should be going.
[Mr. Curran:] I don't want to get
to the station too soon.
Switch on the radio.
I want to hear what's going on at the town hall.
[Mr. Mayor:] That concludes the public works
report.
[Tom McAllister:] I move the department secure
tenders for the painting job.
[Mr. Higgins:] Second.
[Mr. Mayor:] Got it.
And now we come to the special committee report.
[Mr. Higgins:] Mr. Mayor, before hearing the report,
I wish to register...
[Tom McAllister:] Council is out of order.
[Mr. Higgins:] Register my strong disapproval of the tactics used by Councilman Carter
and his crowd of busybodies in bypassing the authority of this council.
[Tom McAllister:] The councilman is out of order.
[Mr. Higgins:] We appointed a committee
to study the proposed plan.
Until that committee acted and council acted,
no one should have stirred up a public furor.
[Howard:] There is some justice to what the
councilor says, but there was no furor at all
until the health program was attacked so
maliciously and unfairly.
[Crowd reacts]
[Mr. Mayor:] If this meeting cannot be conducted
with restraint,
the council will have to adjourn to the city hall.
[Mr. Higgins:] I protest.
Mr. Mayor, these people are vitally concerned in
this issue.
I think it should be settled in their presence.
[Clapping]
[Mr. Mayor:] Well, I only thought...
Certainly we must have order... orderly procedure.
I will refresh your memories on the brief submitted
to council by a panel.
[Woman in crowd:] Don't bother.
[Another woman:] We know it by heart.
[Mr. Mayor:] Are the councilors sufficiently familiar
with the brief?
Very well, in the absence of the committee
chairman...
[Someone shouts:] Yeah, where's Curran?
[Mr. Mayor:] In the absence of Councilor Curran,
I will report for the committee.
[Tom McAllister:] Mr. Mayor, you know as well as  I do
that the committee was stalled by Councilor Curran each time it met.
Three times in all. There's nothing to report.
[Mr. Higgins:] Then why is the subject on the
agenda?
[Howard:] I move it be deferred for at least two weeks.
[Mr. Mayor:] No one to second it.
[Tom McAllister:] I second it.
[Audience mumbles no.]
[Mr. Williams:] Whatsa matter, you afraid to discuss this crackpot scheme?
[Mr. Mayor:] Under the circumstances,
I feel it is wise to defer discussion.
[Mr. Williams] Where's Curran?
Have you got him locked up somewhere?
[Audience shouts, "We want Curran."]
[From radio: "Mr. Mayor, I heartily concur with this
audience’s feelings."]
[Mr. Higgins:] I think the matter should be
hashed out here and now.
[Shorty:] All set Boss?
[From radio: "Where's Curran, I want to hear what he has to say!"]
[Shorty:] Come on, boss, ain't got much time.
[Patsy:] Come on, dad. Hurry up, snap out of it.
[Mr. Curran:] I'm not going to the station.
[Patsy:] Dad!
[Audience shouts, "We want Curran."]
[Music]
[Mr. Williams:] Here's the man that knows the
score.
[Mr. Higgins:] I'd like to hear what Councilor Curran has to say about this health program.
[Mr. Curran:] I think it’s the only thing for Melton.
I found that out, hoped you'd find it out, too
in a couple of weeks.
But never mind that.
Last night, I gave Councilor Carter a sealed envelope with instructions to open it in two weeks.
That was to give me time to make a getaway.
Read it to them!
This should prove to you that....
Well, you'll hear.
[Howard:] I wish to declare that I make this
statement of my own free will
and in a normal state of mind.
For nine years, I have plundered the city of Melton,
in partnership with Marty Williams.
Therefore, I associate myself in every respect
with the charges I lay against Williams.
He is owner of a gambling house and
boardinghouse at 140 Park Drive Way.
[Mr. Williams:] That's a lie!
[Howard:] He sells liquor illegally in his club.
He cooperates with the editor of the Magpie
in a blackmail racket.
Williams and I paid the editor of the Magpie
one thousand dollars
to discredit the health program.
We also paid men to start a whispering campaign against the program.
I suggest to the citizens of Melton that
they either jail Williams or run him out of town.
I've removed myself.
Neither of us have done anything but harm
to this community.
I hope this statement convinces you that the
opposition to the health program was artificial from
[?], so far as its beginnings are concerned.
I suggest those of you who honestly oppose the scheme reconsider your objections
free from the influence of such as Williams and
myself.
[Mr. Curran:] I swear this is true, so help me God.
[Music]
[Newspaper headlines about the scandal.]
[Howard:] Well, I'll never understand it.
It doesn't add up. Not for Curran.
Conscience? Impossible.
[Dr. Ben:] Perhaps not.
[Marian:] It was a brave thing to do.
[Howard:] Oh, it took courage.
Well Ben, what's the next move?
[Daphne:] Got the next move all figured out.
What with all these meeting and stuff, you still ain't fixed that laundry tub.
Wash day tomorrow.
[Howard:] Well, then I'd better get busy on them.
[Daphne:] Ain't laid out what you want washed yet.
[Marian:] Of course, sorry. I'll do it right away.
[Ellen:] I'll help you mother.
[Daphne:] No need.
[Daphne:] No becking and stalling, Ben Edwards.
[Music]